hello everyone and welcome to Game two
of the magnus carlsen invitational match
between Hikaru Nakamura and magnus
carlsen after losing that game one where
Hikaru had the the very very sad Bishop
now Hikaru gets the white pieces and he
gets his chance for retaliation so
without further ado let's check out how
this game went Hikaru with the white
pieces opened with e4 now we have D 5 by
Magnus Knight f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop
the that's not a Bishop Bishop to b5
Hikaru goes for the rule opus actually
Lopez is on the board we have a six more
fees defense Bishop a4 and now Knight to
f6
we have castles b5 better back to b3 and
the Bishop to c5 magnus goes for the uh
sort of the Arkhangelsk variation of the
rule opus which is very popular and
we've been showing more and more of it
on the channel one of Fabiano's favorite
ways to defend against efore and of
course a4 just challenging the b5 phone
we've cooked the b8 and now comes well
although you could play a lot of moose
your c3 being the most popular Hikaru
says that he's not interested in any
heavy theory he just goes force implicit
simplification with knife captures on e5
so a temporary peace sacrifice but he
will reclaim it after Knight characters
with d4 so now he gets to choose well
Magnus gets to choose which piece he
returns and the should capture sending
for was proven to be at the best choice
of moves here we have Queen captures and
now the six Magnus defends the denied
here on e5 with f4 Hikaru pushes it back
Knight to c6 attacking Carlson's Queen
sorry naka Morris Queen and the Queen
back to c3 by nakamura
now saying okay if you grab my for pawn
I'm gonna grab your g7 pawn so we ignite
back to e7 as also the sisa c6 Knight
was under attack
and here we have a trade a captors a
capture some b5 and now there is one
game where Queen te 1 was played but
here he Carlos says to Magnus your king
is still in the center of the board I'm
not just gonna play some slow moves so a
5
and it is as a move 14 that we have a
completely new game now so tonight's the
efore by Magnus attacking he Carlos
Queen Queen to f3 now putting pressure
on the night and the night back to c5
pressuring the bishop here we have
Russia back to ATM not interested in
giving up Bishop for Knight and here
finally Magnus gasps castles to safety
Nakamura continues development with
Bishop to e3 and Bishop the b7 putting
his Bishop on this beautiful diagonal
are showing Hikaru how you should treat
your bishops we have Quinta h3 and now
comes Knight backed up efore it's just
an excellent central outpost for the
night and if it can remain there it's
gonna be a great outpost for Magnus so
tonight's the c3 Nakamura immediately
challenges and Magnus captures as why
not why not mess up he correspond
structure on the Queen side and Bishop
to b5 now our wanting to trade off this
strong light square bishop as well and
he curses okay we can do that but under
my terms
so f5 here he says I'm just gonna push
f6 and start an attack against your king
so Magnus trades with Bishop captures
rook captures and now D captures an e5
grabbing that pawn but that's what he
car wanted he now continues the attack
with f6 and Magnus has to decide whether
he wants to move the knight and play
this position where White would have a
pawn on g7 and a lot of open lines and
files and diagonals or he wants to go
for G captures on f6 which is what he
did in the game it's a bit of a more
risky option but it is what he prefers
so now he's up two points although the
counting points is not what we will be
doing this game Hikaru goes for Bishop
to h6 just attacking that rook and also
there are some very dangerous ideas here
for example if this Knight ever moves
idea like queen g4 check King h8 and
Queen g7 will be made so rook to e8
getting the rook to safety and now not
doing anything rash but first getting
this rook which isn't doing all that
much into the game via rook to a6 just
going here to join the attack so
here in Magnus blockset but in doing so
he also doubles his beep on so road
capture see capture some v6 end and now
comes queen g3 check forcing the night
the block otherwise you're getting king
yet Queen g7 mate
so Knight to g6 and now of course h4
going after the night here and Magnus
has to now figure out how he wants to
defend this there is no good defense
against h6 you are losing that night
that's that's sure even if you move the
king h5 you still can't move the knight
because of checkmate
so here Magnus finds f5 now the thread
is just Queen captures that pawn and h4
and Magnus will get to enjoy his extra
pawn or pawns and he Caro of course
pushes it's the h5 and now Magnus
calculated the deaths that this will be
excellent for him he pushes f4 and now
the point of this is that after you move
the Queen let's take Queen H dream okay
Queen h4 we're gonna get a nice trade
here H characters and H characters in g6
we're gonna get a queen trade here and
if you play something like characters
captures and captures then the problem
is that Magnus has king to g6 and he
traps he carves bishop here and he car
would have to give up the bishop for
some pawns here and we trade down into a
pretty much equal endgame however after
this f4 move Hikaru decided on something
else so feel free to pause the video
here and tried to find this move that he
can't find in this position while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you a sporting that this is actually the
position from the thumbnail
congratulations on finding the decision
tube and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course H captures
and g6 not interested in moving your
Queen to safety point here is that if
Magnus grabs the Queen it's game over
Hikaru just grabs on f7 with check these
are covered by the bishop you have to go
to h8 and now just promote the pawn to a
Queen captures captures you're gonna
give captures to captures and here it's
just a piece up for Hikaru and the
completely winning endgame so Magnus
cannot afford to capture the Queen
instead he captures after this H
captures in g6 he recaptures would be H
bond and
Queen to g4 by Hikaru so the game
continues and here Magnus immediately
plays suboptimal
move with Queen to c8 the point is you
should never leave your control of the
f6 where if you leave control of f6 then
black will just have do what we'll just
have to easy over time creating some
mating threats like like Bishop here
Bishop here you're gonna ship the Queen
to h4 and you can deliver mate here and
also you can just and make a nice rook
that we would look if three rock h3 and
the rook also joins the attack but
cousin did play Queen to c8 and now he
Courage's goes Queen to h4 now he grabs
control of the f6 square magnus goes
Queen the c5 trek with King to h2 and
now Queen to d6 keeping an eye on the f6
square now but now it's too late and
here
Bishop to g5 a Hikaru now reclaims
control of f6 he wants the play just
bishop here and delivers checkmate on h8
so Magnus has to defend and he defends
with f5 the problem with King here
guarding this way is that you have
several ways how to tackle it but most
most a reasonable one would be rogue d1
you offer a rook for for this checkmate
rook f6 followed by Queen tha so after
the Queen moves
now you go Queen h6 check King g8 and
rugby three and again there's no defense
against Luke h3 fall by Queen tha if you
really persist efore rock h3 and now
Queen B 5 guarding the a traits where
it's still just winning Queen h7 check
Bishop covers d7 sorry just gonna
deliver check here and after a nice
trade here you're just gonna pick up the
rook as well and of course completely
winning for white so after this Queen
Bishop to g5 King G 7 doesn't work
Magnus tries f5 but now rook f3 again
with the same idea going for rook to h3
and Magnus now uses his last resort
efore he wants to kick away the rook and
play a free to deliver a discovery here
but nakamura still goes for rook to h3
with f3 with check and now not moving
queen but rather Bishop to f4 just
attacking Carlson's Queen Queen to d7
and now of course Queen to h8 with check
with King to f7 wrote the h7 with King
e6 and now of course not
grabbing the Queen but rather here he
called delivers and mate in one with
Queen to e5 and this is checkmate on the
board and Nakamura equalizes it's
one-to-one now so two more games to be
played in there Magnus and rotational
match and if they're gonna be as
exciting as the first two games
well III am very happy with that and I
do hope you are as well so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Frank ohms
Yuri David Adam Cavanaugh kumara gana
pivara Pugh and Leon Byron for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with some more videos from the
Magnus Invitational Tournament
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day